si pulgares atrás para que
específicamente de balance ha sido la
declaración que ofreció el día de hoy el
ministro de interior y justicia donde
expresaba precisamente que la violencia
se ha incrementado en la capital de la
amazonía la provincia de pastaza
específicamente ha dicho que no pueden
garantizar ya la seguridad en este lugar
donde como tú lo has indicado es 18
funcionarios que se encuentran
desaparecidos y que el día de ayer se
vivió una de las jornadas más intensas
durante estos 10 días de movilizaciones
en este sentido también la oea ha
expresado preocupación ante los
discursos de golpes algunos sectores del
movimiento indígena recuerda que hay
algunos sectores que han dicho que no
dejarán las calles hasta que no con
conseguir la salida del gobierno por
parte del presidente de este país
guillermo lasso de igual forma también
el ministro de interior y justicia ha
dicho que los denunciará específicamente
se refería a los dirigentes indígenas
quienes ha dicho que los denunciara ante
la fiscalía por estas movilizaciones de
igual forma también asegura que en esa
ciudad en la provincia de pastaza no se
puede y mantener la seguridad pero yo me
encuentro en este momento en lo que ha
sido en la zona de reclamo de los
movimientos indígenas detrás de mí ha
estado fuertemente custodiada y el olor
a gas lacrimógenos las detonaciones y
las distintas protestas ha sido lo que
ha caracterizado el día de hoy en esta
zona recordemos y que es el décimo día
de movilizaciones indígenas
específicamente la unidad de isa ha
dicho que hasta no encontrar soluciones
no saldrán de las calles andrés
gustavo cuéntenos qué ha sucedido con el
intento de diálogo entre las partes
y específicamente ante la solicitud de
un diálogo en la presentación de
propuestas por parte de la conae y la
intermediación de aproximadamente 300
organizaciones civiles el diálogo se ha
estancado específicamente la unidad y se
ha dicho que luego de haber asistido a
cuatro diálogos previos él considera que
esta situación no amerita una
intervención una mediación por parte de
organizaciones civiles de ha dicho o más
bien que desea una mediación ha
condicionado al ejecutivo en nacional de
levantar la militarización de toda esta
zona levantar también el estado de
excepción y sobre todo toda esta zona
que bordea la casa de la cultura y el
parque del arbolito sea desmilitarizada
por lo tanto también leonidas iza hizo
un llamado a distintas organizaciones
sociales a que luego de realizar una
asamblea popular pudieran responder así
al presidente de la república pero hasta
este momento el diálogo se ha frenado y
no se avisará una pronta solución en los
próximos días